let's say we were a democracy the libs
don't care at all about democracy for
the libs and I don't think they're doing
this in any nefarious way I think they
genuinely believe that democracy is
synonymous with liberalism the Democracy
can elect right-wing governments just
the same as they can elect the libs
that's what happened in Hungary with
Victor Urbana that's what happened in
Italy with Georgia Maloney that's what
happened in the UK with the brexit
that's what happened in America with
Trump and they just can't accept that so
whenever that happens whenever the
people elect a conservative they say
this is an attack on our democracy which
is obviously incoherent that's a
internally a contradiction if you were
to say that but it's just because they
mean by democracy liberalism and so
anytime liberalism fails they say it's
illegitimate